[Musica]
[Applauso]
la scienza
esattamente come la fortuna e l'amore e
blind
e di questa blindness ne ha fatto un
potere ora che la fortuna sia ceca
l'abbiamo capito un po di tempo ormai si
è capito non guarda la famosa dea
bendata
sull'amore insomma lì c'era insomma un
po un dibattito io ho visto ultimamente
una serie su netflix chiama love is
blind e loro dimostrano attraverso uno
speedy un esperimento sociale che ci si
può innamorare senza guardarsi
ma lasciamo fare sta cosa loro insomma
né occupiamoci di scienza io stasera
sono qui per farvi vedere come per la
scienza essere blind e stato un percorso
straordinario nella storia e ci ha
portato a quello che noi abbiamo oggi ma
voi sapete che io sono un prof
attraverso fatto
o pare
ci siano sullo stesso fatto che sono pro
fano huppert e che di solito sono
abituato a parlare con le classi quindi
voi sa se risiede la mia classe io vi
devo interrogare hai capito dobbiamo
giocarcela questa cosa qua e ti li
tireremo un po dei concetti che fanno
parte della vita di tutti i giorni
perché la blindness cioè il fatto che la
scienza non riesca a vedere è riuscita
ad attraversare questo ea creare delle
formule ed essere creativa e a darci
quello che ci ha dato avviene a diversi
livelli il livello più intuitivo e
quello della vita di tutti i giorni
facciamo una costante proviamo pronti il
massimo quel massimo può succedere il
biglietto 14 ve n'è andato a posto
anche la piccionaia da sopra pronti a
rispondere che non è che insomma ha
capito non è che non si curano un dvd
dove loro sono un po più sfigati perché
stanno avanti sono costrette a risponde
all'attenzione se io vi faccio vedere
con la mia lavagnetta sta cosa qua
abbiamo la lavagnetta e io ho un oggetto
sulla lavagna allora la domanda è
questo oggetto è fermo ci sono delle
forze in gioco
via le telefonate
si senta quali sono le forze poi dite di
te fatto non vi preoccupate
la forza peso sento la signora e poi
la reazione vincolare fantastico
stanno funzionando in sedi fisiche
aiutino cosa non funziona bravo bio bio
follower ci sono questi due sì e no c'è
pezzo di 0
poi mandami un messaggio che facevo in
borsa
ci sarebbe veramente un altra forza in
gioco però aspettando ce la giochiamo
dopo fra un attimo e c'è un effetto
sorpresa la progettazione agitato faccio
queste cose può strade che sembrano
delle magie allora questa storia qua
della forza peso e della reazione
vincolare cioè voi pensate che sia una
cosa così banale ma ragazzi non è banale
perché dalla fisica aristotelis todt e
le ricevo un corte fermo non ci sono
forze poi arriva newton licata la meno
in testa e dice la forza la fisica
newtoniana le forze i pianeti si
attraggono e ci sono delle forze che
fanno altre aree chiarita loro comincia
a vedere la forza ma la forza non si
vede ma c'è la forza c'è è fondamentale
poi arriva lui
hashtag meraviglioso einstein
arriva la tesi di laurea e dice scusa
lui su che cosa ha fatto la tesi lauree
no io ho voluto fare una tesi
sull'universo dei comuni no non ridete
vero dice ho riscritto l'universo e lui
dice quella forza che tanto imbarazzava
newton
in realtà non è una vera e propria forza
e quello spazio tempo che permea
l'universo
che si deforma in presenza delle grandi
masse qui di newton rovescia tutto voi
direte allora è superata quella visione
blind di newton delle forze no perché
noi grazie a quella visione blinding
newton mandiamo i satelliti in orbita
andiamo a fare viaggi fuori dal sistema
della terra superiamo la gravità
terrestre grazie alla alle leggi di
newton abbiamo fatto abbiamo fatto tutta
la fisica tutta la meccanica
grazie ad einstein abbiamo aggiustato il
tiro perché einstein ci ha dato la
possibilità per esempio di fare una
correzione relativistica sulle
connessioni dei satelliti vabbè poi la
relatività generale di einstein realtà
ha fatto tanto altro ci spiega che le
particelle che attraversano le
particelle che arrivano dal cosmo che
attraversano la nostra atmosfera
arrivano oltrepassano la terra perché
andando quasi alla velocità della luce
vivono un tempo rallentato tutto questo
signori non si vede e gli scienziati
grazie alla creatività
e alla matematica perché la scienza è
esatta scrive le leggi in maniera
matematica ha fatto una cosa pazzesca
torniamo alla lavagna va detto che c'era
l'altra forza in gioco e mola vedrete
anche se non la vedrete
schena blind serate peso così dice the
blind 19 minuti e 20 proposta guardare
cosa ne sono viste a mezzanotte alla se
io faccio sta cosa qua
qual è l'altra forza in gioco
una signora
l'avevo sentito la che c'è un altro
follower di lo forte
l'attrito l'altro follo quest'anno
applauso
[Applauso]
l'attrito
c'è ragazzi sta storia dell'attrito la
dovete sentire luce vede però sta se io
sto in piedi qua fermo e grazie
all'attrito altro che è quella storia lì
che mondo sarebbe senza non lo posso
dire perché la pubblicità poi a una
grande azienda italiana che mondo
sarebbe senza attrito c'è quest'altra
forza che non si vede
fa tutto e vi spiego un fatto
meraviglioso può essere state a dubai
chi è stata dubai ha visto quelli più
grande il palazzo più alto del mondo il
bus khalifa io sono stato l'anno scorso
è chiaramente ho approfittato ho fatto
un video sulla fisica del boss khalifa
mi sono andato a studiare un po come è
stato costruito sto palazzo come è stato
messo in piedi signori il bus khalifa è
chiamato nel deserto
non è vero
resta piantato alcol hanno fatto tu hai
pensato chissà di ingegneria cruz
khalifa come avranno fatto a pianta
soccorso nel deserto che pesa pesa mag
non so quanti 105 100 milioni chi no
loro hanno sfruttato la forza invisibile
dell'attrito perché sotto il bus carità
ci sono
196 i pali di calcestruzzo
conficcati nella sabbia sotto la sabbia
st un'antica polvere di con chili e chi
se ne frega però i pali cassani me e
dell attrito che ti tiene fermi voi
diritto non ci credo e io vi faccio fare
un esperimento però dovete fare a casa
io lo volevo portare qua l'esperimento
avete le pagine gialle
l'avete conservate le pagine gialle gli
elenchi telefonici gli elenchi
telefonici che usavano una volta
qualcuno ce li ha in casa ma è stanotte
quando torni signora devi fare se
esperimento
perché è bellissimo al 3d praticamente
questi eletti metti tu stanotte e metti
un foglio sull'altro un foglio
sull'altro ci vuole proprio tutta la
notte però ragazzi se fate sta cosa
domani mattina
avis anatemi che se sono ancora pari a
te vengo a trovarla e facciamo il tic
toc sera virale
sì perché ci mettiamo io la signora a
tirare uno da una parte o dall'altra
non si staccano e se tu attacchi due
macchine due corsi due fuoristrada da
una parte dall'altra con le ganasce
signori sono serio lo so che queste
atene dario non si staccano è la forza
d'attrito gli ingegneri
noi dovremo usare una colla potente no
di ingegneri è semplice
perché c'è la fisica a disposizione c'è
quello che non si vede le forze
l'attrito signora fallo
c'era perché bellissimo 800 non
tantissimo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no
svetta addetti qua mi sto perdendo lo
sto allungando la sta passando il te
allora vi ho detto il fatto qui siamo
giovane il mondo di tutti i giorni
andiamo a vedere quello che non si vede
le particelle scusa signora tu come te
le immagini l'atomo di che lo devo
disegnare è veloce che sta passando il
tempo
più o meno così allora l'atomo così me
l'hanno insegnato così e non è così
e lo sapete perché perché non si vede
blind
si vede però la fisica ha capito come
fatto perché perché noi abbiamo degli
strumenti che indagano le particelle
chiudiamo questi fasci di particelle e
li facciamo collidere al cern che bello
che bello i laboratori l'acceleratore
più grande del mondo fai collidere
queste particelle e un certo hashtag
meraviglioso einstein disse fat attendo
che la massa energia e l'energia può
trasformarsi in massa tu fai collidere
queste particelle e da queste collisioni
escono fasci di particelle che non vedi
ma che fai passare in mezzo a tutta una
serie di piastre al silicio e magneti li
fa i pur validi fi tracciare perché le
particelle sono cariche e quindi
lasciano una traccia e vedi il loro
percorso e capisci che ma sanno e
capisci come gida come girano la carica
che hanno il momento angolare capisci
tutto ma non le vedi ma la fisica andata
oltre ma do ancora out allora dice sotto
la particella particella di che cos'è
ecco se io ti dico solo signora dentro
il crotone stanno delle particelle tu
dici veloce si sa nicolardi cuork see
the work signore un'altra follo eroga
anche da anche grazie per il tempo che
qua passa allora i fisici del set del 70
60 fisico italiano veneziano dice ma
dentro le particelle che sono quelle
elementari l'elettrone elementare non
dovrebbe avere nulla dentro veramente
non c'è nulla non è vero non è possibile
che non c'è nulla perché noi queste
particelle non le abbiamo viste e non
sappiamo neanche come si comportano la
nube elettronica l'atomo di share
edinger per karachi il lato non è così
magari non è così cioè diverso ma non lo
puoi vedere non è quello che la mente
umana pensa perché la mente umana guarda
noi guardiamo con gli occhi e
immaginiamo stato forse questa è un
pianeta del sistema solare ma non è così
allora veneziano in magia le particelle
all'interno come qualcosa che vivrà come
delle stringhe che vibrano insieme vi
faccio un esempio
ascoltate questo
a me
[Musica]
questo è un solo suono
ascoltate questo invece
[Musica]
non ci sono santi
tante corde
ecco che canta
così
[Musica]
e allora lui immagina l'amat e immagine
all'interno della particella come tante
corde vibranti e la vibrazione di queste
corde determina l'identità di quella
particella la teoria delle stringhe
non è ancora dimostrata siamo dentro la
materia siamo dentro alla particella
siamo alla lunghezza di planck cioè
quella cosa più corta che più corto non
ci può essere nell'universo arriveremo a
capire anche questo ma non abbiamo mai
visto ma quello che la scienza non vede
riesce poi a prevederle è questa la cosa
meravigliosa e poi l'ultimo minuto
ammazza come con il tempo va dicendo e
di là no è tanto sono tanti 15 minuti
se ti sto fatto allora il pianeti del
sistema solare facciamo un bel grafico
quelli più vicini al sole vanno più
veloce quelli più lontani vanno più
lento sto parlando del moto di
rivoluzione a quelli più vicini minore
distanza maggiore velocità
proporzionalità
bravi inversa fatta o da state seguendo
tutte le elezioni sono contento allora
se tu metti i pianeti del sistema solare
i vari pianeti su un grafico
distanza velocità ottiene sta roba qua
c'è ottieni che mano mano che la
distanza aumenta dal sole la velocità
diminuisce benissimo la galassia
se voi guardate le foto regala sono
molto simili e sistemi solari non sono
delle spirali rotanti
40 anni fa vengono fatte delle
osservazioni sulle galassie guardate che
cosa succede che le stelle più lontane
invece di comportarsi così si comportano
così
cioè hanno grande velocità anche le
stelle più lontane la galassia ma lo
sapete come risponde alla fisica qui c'è
della materia che non vediamo la fisica
la chiama materia oscura e probabilmente
sarà oggetto di studi del futuro se
stasera avrete avuto modo di portare un
pezzo di scienza a casa come hanno fatto
gli scienziati avrete allora compreso il
potere della scienza blind
grazie